billions of people are going to get
smaller as a result of This Global reset
this reset is going to be create massive
opportunities this is where wealth is
created in very short periods of time
anybody can get this one no matter what
happens today I'm going to wake up
Saturday morning and I'll be like I'm
starting over from zero right I'm not
starting from where I'm from where
yesterday and I'm starting from zero
that's right and so I keep accumulating
like that I don't mean money I mean
customer success and that becomes the
unbreakable business that we talk about
the crew breaks before the ship goes so
that's what's going to happen in
recession your crew is going to break up
loyal people are going to blow off
people are going to quit jobs that
should not good jobs you're not getting
out the fire crew they're just going to
quit like like people go Looney Tunes
because there's bad news everywhere no
matter how big and powerful you get you
still have Achilles seals your business
plan becomes your business plan you know
it becomes the thing that like if I know
your business plan then I can
participate in your business plan
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because when I
started my first business I really
struggled to believe myself I was making
300 bucks a month and quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the stories of
successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because I still need
the videos for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best Grant
Cardone and my take on his top 10 rules
of success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one expand your thinking nothing's
really happened by the way in these
recessions nothing really changed it's
just an illusion that somehow oh my God
there's no money now now the the money's
still there nothing's really changed
except everybody's mindset everybody
still has to eat they still have to wear
clothes they still have to travel they
still want to have sex and procreate and
have fun and go to the movies and
everybody wants to do the same stuff you
still got eight billion people on the
planet growing every day the the thing
is there's fewer people going for it
this is what I always say man there's
there's a an abundance amount of money
on planet Earth and a shortage of people
going after it and this is the perfect
time this is it go all out bro this is
it because what happens if you 10x your
efforts for for just short periods of
time maybe six or eight or nine months
and start building out a new network of
people what happens is people are going
to back out
and you're gonna look up you'll be like
there's only three or four of us on the
field
like there's only going to be a handful
of people playing the game everybody
else is just just oh I'm grateful you
know we're we're better off than the
pakistanians and the Palestinians in the
in the Cubans and the it's all you're
always comparing yourself to some third
world country that's not developed this
is what people do all the time by the
way okay uh there's some Village in
Africa where you know they don't have
running water I hear this story all the
time these people you ever been to
Africa we have food you know you don't
even know what you're talking about
you're comparing you could always find
somebody worse off to compare yourself
to when what you should be doing instead
looking up is setting an example for all
the people that are below you or side of
you they're suffering and say no man we
should be expanding and have prosperity
in all times especially in tough times
rule number two is set the right target
most people just simply have the wrong
target
most small businesses in America Break
Even or lose money because they have
their own Target they're just like I
just want to make 70 grand out of my
business I want to own my business I
want to be the boss the boss of what
you know and so so first thing we do is
fix the target what is the target this
reset is going to be create massive
opportunities this is where wealth is
created in very short periods of time
anybody can get this well because the
big money is going to sideline it has to
sideline because it's public
a little more complicated but they're
public so they have to be careful okay
and you don't you need to take risks
right now rule number three is raise
your game intention is senior to
mechanics
and I was like that that was a game
changer for me I'm like man I need to
keep for me that means like
my understanding of that concept is the
intention where I want to get
not not am I a good person or not what
the goal or Target is needs to be 80
percent
of my energy
so I'm going to get to 5 billion now the
next thing I'm going to do
I'm not going to take a piece of paper
out I might take a piece of paper out
figure out how many deals I need to do
but that's where it becomes problematic
because I'm like okay if my average deal
size is 50 million and I need to get to
50 billion I need a thousand deals right
like I ain't got I can't I can't even
buy one deal right now much less a
thousand and then you get stuck in this
problem this bigger problem and then
you're like there's no way and you give
up on your goal and your intention now
and then you start cutting everything
that's why if you've ever heard me say
never reduce the target that's what I
was talking about don't reduce the
target increase the activity
to the point to where your goals in my
case my goals should be so big that it
gives me new questions to ask
and the new question would be who do I
need to meet to do a 50 billion dollar
deal right right the buddies that I have
right now in clubhouse Jonathan Jerry
Glenn David spezak Brian been stuck they
can't help me dude correct
those people cannot help me get to 50
billion they can they can they can be
buddies sure
so that's why if you look at that list
of people I gave you earlier that I'm
studying oh yeah
they've all done 50 billion and more
right
so that's what I need to start real say
what did these cats do who who do they
know what do they now now I'll just tell
you another thing that that is crazy
because I just found this out I was I
was talking to some Wall Street guys and
I'm like do that I hate these Wall
Street people
and I said they're just I'm just not
accepted there I'm not like them and the
guy looked at me says bro it's because
you're talking to the wrong people he
didn't say bro by the way but he says
it's because Grant he's like Grant
you're not talking to the top of the
food chain
the top of the food chain
is exactly like you that's interesting
they would never judge you they would
never criticize you they would only
admire you they would want to pick up
the bill with you they would think they
were with a brother
he says it's everybody they hired below
him that is threatened by you
they said the reason you don't feel
comfortable talking to these people is
because you're talking to one level
below who you should be talking to rule
number four is make a decision the first
thing you have to do when you want to do
anything you have to make a decision a
lot of people brush over this and so oh
I got to make a decision yeah no but you
have to make a decision
that you're going you're not going to be
the same in any event like the mo this
moment that you're having right now on
the internet watching us in this
interview you cannot re-produce this
moment you can wish it want it walk on
fire to get it you cannot reproduce it
can't happen no matter how many
decisions you make you cannot reproduce
this one moment
the future however can be created out of
decisions like what decisions am I going
to make
to go from here to there if I don't make
that decision I don't go there
everything everything follows a decision
whether you know it or not billions of
people not Millions not hundreds of
millions billions of people are going to
get smaller as a result of This Global
reset
these are resets these are these are
redistributions of wealth whether you
believe it or not if you go back the
last couple hundred years they've been
doing this over and over again you know
there's this old thing about if you took
all the money on the planet
equally distributed to everyone it would
somehow in a very short period of Time
end up in the same hands why because
those people have specific strategies
one they're making decisions to create
wealth for themselves two massive wealth
there's not little bits of wealth they
want massive amounts of wealth okay two
they they
um they know how to Market themselves
I'm not talking about social media
marketing I'm talking about how do I
just Market myself with you or with you
right now how do I Market My Brand Apple
knows how to do it Coca-Cola General
Electric the the companies that are hot
Netflix knows how to do it you have to
learn how to do that in order to get
money to follow attention so the first
pillar is the decision to get bigger you
and your family have to make this
like you and your wife yeah my wife and
I okay my kids my kids are on board I
got an 11 year old and 13 year old like
look our decision is to get bigger and
that requires some sacrifices also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is learn to be
strategic you're very Scrappy and so
it's like do you ever worry like calling
out the black rocks and these guys I
mean you're basically you know
well it's not a good thing to do if
you're going to stay small
but if you have what they want they'll
they'll forgive you
so what we're doing is we're very
strategic about collecting
the kind of assets that they are forced
to eat okay they they don't they know no
matter how big and powerful you get you
still have Achilles seals
right your your your your your business
plan becomes your
business plan
you know it becomes the thing that like
if I know your business plan then
I can participate in your business plan
so I can become a necessary evil
to the black rock or you know maybe they
could buy you someday maybe or maybe
yeah maybe we do the flippy dippy and I
make my big move bro look you don't
think that these big giants can't fall
they have fallen like all you got to do
is go back hundreds of years man rule
number six is act like you're broke just
assume that 40 million people are going
to be put out of work dude I would act
like I'm gonna 40 million people gonna
be put out of work at one weekend that's
what I would go into January saying the
entire world is going to shut down uh
you're not going to be able to get
anything you won't be able to get
anybody on the phone you won't be able
to use your internet like just go
violent paranoid yeah and and that way
you're going to be right
because even if none of that happens
you're gonna You're Gonna Act
appropriately that's right which is how
people should act all the time that's
how I act all the time I'm always acting
like like you're broke no I'm always
broke yeah but I'm always broke yeah so
I like that a lot you know because no
matter how much success I achieve today
no matter what happens today I'm gonna
wake up Saturday morning
and I'll be like I'm starting over from
zero again right I'm not starting from
where I'm where yesterday and I'm
starting from zero that's right and so I
keep accumulating like that I don't mean
money I mean customer success and that
becomes the unbreakable business that we
talk about rule number seven is 10x
everything I was on a boat a 200 foot
yacht in in south of France and I said
man when you guys are coming through
storms 30 and 40 foot weights like he's
like man we don't worry about the ship
we worry about the crew crew breaks
before the ship does
so that's what's going to happen in
recession your crew is going to break up
loyal people are going to blow off
people are going to quit jobs that
should not quit jobs you're not going to
have to fire people they're just going
to quit like like people go Looney Tunes
okay because there's bad news everywhere
so first thing is hey set a new Target
for 2023 and it's going to be a big
Target it's gonna be giant something
that terrifies you second day we're
gonna handle marketing how much
marketing would you have to do to tell a
story
because you're going to be able to buy
ads for a fraction
like we're we're gonna hit we're going
to start pounding Twitter right now
because I know dot uh ad dollars are
moving away from Elon right now so I'll
go in and say you know I'll be I'll be a
huckleberry
okay so we're looking for opportunities
right but that follows that decision
making we want to 10x to our business I
do 150 million dollars a year I want to
do I'm going to figure out how to do a
billion five a year in sales I have to
10x mate
so I need a strategy right Marketing
sales then it's gonna be like how big a
sales team do I need to start Gathering
these sales to monetize and this this
activity we're going to make I need
other communities I need other languages
for me to do a billion dollars I cannot
do it on only English-speaking people
you need you you need like you said you
need people that don't look like you
Mandarin Hispanic kids
snapchatters tick talkers collaboration
you get me an audience that I don't have
like like that's what that's what has to
happen rule number eight is learn to
communicate if you go out on the street
and communicate and there's nobody there
to listen
did you did you actually say anything if
you send an email and it hits a junk box
and nobody saw it did did you actually
communicate
if I communicate to you and you don't
actually duplicate the communication did
the communication take place there's a
lot of sales people out there in fact I
would say most sales people a majority
somewhere above three out of four
communicate
and there is no communication there's no
duplication in the communication
I know I know public speakers that get
on stage and speak to
100 people or 300 people or 30 000
people there's really no communication
people in the back of the room never had
their attention never had their full
attention if you've ever seen a zoom
meeting or a corporate meeting and dude
people come in the meeting and they're
all like there's this there's this you
know the delay coming in and then and
people you know can't get anybody's
attention and people are showing up like
there's no communication going on but
you think you did a meeting and then you
wonder why there's no results guess what
it's because there was no communication
even though you spent your time and
energy what does it say
did it really happen it never happened
okay so if if you communicate and it's
not duplicated did it really happen
you're going home and I said oh I'm so
tired I worked so hard really the reason
you feel so tired is because you did
something and it got nothing that
actually was never done because it
wasn't duplicated as opposed to they
where you communicate clearly and you
get results and people buy from you you
go home you're like man it's the best
day of my life
you're renewed why because the
communication went both ways so that
requires you get a stage it requires you
get an audience it requires you to get
attention there's an exact science to
grabbing someone's full attention I'm
not talking about trickery and mimicry
and uh some of these Neuroscience
bullish Sciences I'm talking about
straight up hey
do you hear what I'm saying to you
we are going to go into a massive
recession it's going to affect your
family
did I get your attention did you hear
what I said hey tell me what I just said
and then I get an audience to say yeah
dude you just said my family is going to
get spanked
and it's going to hurt
and then I said yes exactly what I said
your family's gonna get beat up
and you can do something about it do you
want to
see I didn't get a clear communication
because I got attention so there's an
exact science to that even some of the
best sales people I know don't do that
well rule number nine is focus on
business number one it's real it's
possible no matter what you hear or see
or you know
uh any level of success is real second
thing I would tell young people is don't
focus on sports and entertainment you
know focus on business
you know I I my career will Outlast
every baseball player basketball player
rapper and performer I can go until I'm
99 years old
uh I don't need any special talent
uh the next thing I would tell people is
looking best in yourself don't don't
just invest in yourself to go to college
there's so many better investments in
education like I wouldn't go to college
again personally
I would invest in myself
uh every day I spend an hour to two
hours studying super successful people
on YouTube animal number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
stop making excuses how to be a
billionaire I wanna be a billionaire I
want to be a billionaire you know that's
all man I was summing that song I'm like
I want to be a billionaire and a lady
came up to me after this meeting I did
this morning in Los Angeles she says I
just want to be a millionaire I'm like
you already are a millionaire she's like
what do you mean I'm like look
everybody's a millionaire or something
everybody is a millionaire come on how
many times have you had gas at least a
million times in your lifetime right how
many times have you took a breath of air
at least a million times how many times
has your heart beated your heart beat it
that's not even a word but how many
times does that happen right at least a
million times see most people are
millionaires in many things they're just
not like looking at what they're a
millionaire at being a millionaire is
not that difficult I'm telling you it's
not that difficult look how many people
do you know that are millionaires and
excuses millionaires in being late
millionaires in not making things work
how about a millionaire at failing how
about a millionaire at dreams see how
about a millionaire at thoughts look if
you can be a millionaire that easily in
so many different areas once you just
put your focus down and say hey now I'm
going to be a millionaire at money
because that's what it is it's about
Focus what are you focused on excuses
reasons Alibis justifications being late
eating too much chocolate you think you
hadn't had a million pieces of chocolate
in your lifetime probably how if you
overeaten a million times do you have a
million calories of consumption in your
lifetime sure a million breaths of air
million heartbeats you're a millionaire
already just change the way you're
thinking about it hey now I want to Be a
Millionaire on money now I want to now I
want to create enough wealth for myself
and my family so I can actually take
care of them folks that's not a bad
thing oh and by the way you guys that
say oh money won't make you happy look
you're just a millionaire excuses you're
a millionaire in little quotes that mean
nothing and go nowhere what are you
going to be a Millionaire on
the 10x rule is based on look your the
goals people are setting are too small
you know I want to get a good job
I want to get married I want to be happy
the goals are wrong
and I hate to tell somebody their goals
are wrong but I'm just I don't know that
your goals are wrong you know I know
that my goals have always been too small
everything I have done in my life
has not been
I have underestimated what I could do
every time I've gotten to where I got I
was like dang dude I could have that
wasn't even that hard like it wasn't
even that difficult and it got easier as
I got rid of the people that said I
couldn't do it
mostly it wasn't really people saying I
couldn't do it it was mostly people
saying dude but why do you need to they
were requesting why I need to right so
if your kid decides man he wants to be
he don't want to be an astronaut he's
like I don't want to be an astronaut
dude
I want to be the guy that creates the
company
that sends
millions of people to another planet
see he's like why would I want to be the
pilot dude he's just another worker I
want to be I want to be the Elon Musk
that figured it out right so so and and
you'll be like man just be happy to be
an astronaut right but but he's got a
bigger dream and and we should all that
that's the first thing I would tell
people look whatever you think
your dream is
one you gotta add money you got it
people people are having goals and
dreams about money you know there's all
these quotes on the internet a goal
without a date is merely a wish it will
never happen whatever dude dude a goal
without money attached to it okay is
something that will never be
accomplished because there is no goal on
this planet that doesn't require money
including happy to be happy
you need money
and and uh your audience is I'd love to
see their comments like you cannot be
happy without money the only way you can
be happy and broke is to be insane yeah
because the only an insane person would
say yeah dude we're all good
I don't know where food's coming from
tonight but I'm happy that means well I
don't know where you how you're paying
for your drugs
because you can't be happy knowing I
can't pay for the next meal it's just
it's it's it's mentally impossible your
department and your household has a
financial statement
if you if you look up the word economics
in the dictionary economics means
management of a household and this is
where people go a little fuzzy right now
you could be going fuzzy
what's he talking about this I'm talking
about your damn money
just right on here my damn money
that's what finances is it's my money
you know how many have you seen that
little t-shirt I got who's got my money
that that's what this is a professional
baseball player said he was retired he's
a retired professional baseball player
he's like he's in business for himself
now he's like when you said who's got my
money he's like literally changed my
entire business
he's like I was spending time on a bunch
of complicated stuff
and wasn't doing what I knew to do in
baseball in baseball what is if you're a
batter what's the game
get on base that it's not hit them all
it's get on base
you could get hit by the ball
and you'll celebrate yourself
right it's get on base once you get on
base what's the next thing you want to
do
you want to advance
okay in finance you need to advance your
finances everybody agreed the way to
advance finances is not to to shrink the
bottom two-thirds of this statement it
is to grow the top line of the statement
same thing for your household your
household needs more income Chris the
police officer if he wants more money he
cannot reduce his expenses as far as he
can raise his income
you can only reduce your expenses to
zero everybody agree
I can only reduce so far
what can I do with income if Chris got
really creative how far could his income
go
it's Unstoppable it's unlimited he can
only no matter how bright he is or how
smart he is a company an individual
household can only take their expenses
so low one of the things that
to me is the most difficult thing in my
entire career is becoming a top producer
because the moment you become a top
producer you become susceptible
to thinking you have the life
I grew up in a little town in Louisiana
a little small town about 60 000 people
uh you probably hear the accent and uh I
I grew up in a middle as a middle class
family my my dad died when I was 10
years old my mother raised us and my
mother constantly told me how proud I
should be of myself
how many of you got a mother like that
you should be so proud of yourself okay
uh every time my mom was my best friend
and every time I would have a success it
didn't matter whether I was 18 years old
or 48 years old anytime I had a success
she was the first person I called I
wouldn't call my girlfriend wouldn't
call my wife wouldn't call any of the
people that were closest to me I called
my mom and say mom you never believe I
just bought a real estate deal I started
this company I bought my first real
estate deal it's 38 units it's four
million dollars and she'd be like that's
awesome I love you Just the Way You Are
and I'm like okay okay thanks she told
me that a thousand times how many had a
parent tell you I love you that's great
that's great you made 160 Grand last
year
but I love you just the way you are let
me hear that okay that's right out of
the 10x rule I don't know if you know
that that's right out of the four
actions
anybody know what action it is
average average I'm doing well okay
there's four levels of action number one
is I do nothing
if I rewrote this book I would take that
out that's actually impossible to do
nothing at all is impossible try doing
it right now
actually not true I wouldn't put it in
the book If I rewrote it the second
level of action is
um to retreat this is what most people
do by the way
how many had a commitment to work out
today
and didn't
okay okay
I was up late whatever you came up with
whatever reason I'm gonna make the call
by the way any intrigued in life in
single
word commitment to retreat when it
matters
so so every time you make a decision you
just need to be aware that what are you
doing here okay there's only four things
you can do in any given day right you
could do nothing you could Retreat or
you could do this average
now I know you guys are being told that
you're the top
you're the top you're the best you made
it to Miami but I'm just going to tell
you right now ain't not a person in this
room is above number three
no I'm not there
okay and I know how much I'm grinding
every day how much I'm pushing every day
how many how many hours I put in today
what's the maximum number of hours you
can do in a day
not if you add people
if you added people you got to think
beyond the 24th Thing Once you guys get
committed once you get committed then
you will come up with Solutions outside
the physical universe
okay you're already doing that your
space is your space is bizarre okay here
there's a bunch of people in the room
that
that like I don't know anything about
technology
I'm 61 years old I was born in 1958. I
am supposed to be outside of that moment
of Technology yet I'm probably one of
the top five social media people in the
world today
banging on Instagram and Snapchat and
Linkedin and Google Plus that'll go away
using all these mechanisms to try to get
attention so that I can operate
at this level 10x thing this massive
level that is always changing by the way
you can't 10x something people are like
man I'd write the book If I wrote the
book I'd write it 11x I'm like that's
because you don't understand 10x dude
10x is a multiplier
it's 10x which is a hundred
okay so what what I do what I did in it
when Lehman collapsed I wrote the 10x
Rule and I wrote the book because I
realized I had done something wrong that
book was written for me and the reason
when I closed the book The reason I was
like ah whatever I had figured out what
I had done wrong okay I had to embrace
the the the idea that three or four
million dollars in a bank and a house
paid for and two cars and a marriage and
I got it better than everybody else and
my mama loves me just the way I am
was all this this middle class
this American particularly here in
America how many of you live in America
okay in America the middle class it is
the sleeping chamber
on planet Earth
okay people come here people come here
they come from India and China come to
here to get a middle class dude I don't
want anything to do with this
okay your middle class you will not
change the world
you might change your house you might
change the education your little kids
get okay they get to go to Texas A M big
deal right he told me that he went to
Texas I said oh that had to screw you up
bad just going to college
well because what do they manufacture at
college
they may they manufacture average people
at college
so so I want to challenge you today okay
I want to challenge you today I want to
challenge you today to start thinking
hey wait a minute am I even a top
producer Money Follows attention
and attention follows money
you know you guys have heard probably
heard me say before Money Follows
attention Money Follows attention you
need to hear the second side of this
attention follows money too anybody
thinks attention doesn't follow money
you're wrong tension follows money
attention follows success on this planet
the way you measure thing is how much
money do they make
okay Elon Musk became one of the richest
people in the world last week
it's for real
they've been counting him out man his
car companies worth more than four Motor
Company a day like he sells he sells you
know a tenth of what they sell Like
Money Follows attention and attention
follows money be successful with your
money
these big real estate deals we're doing
man I'm telling you man it's got a lot
of people's attention
okay people's attention goes to what
people are doing
so the way for you to spread that
message is to be an example people need
man people need help why am I doing this
I am the only guy in the real estate
space doing an event like this like I'm
not trying to sell you don't have to buy
a course for me you don't have to do
anything with me I'd love for you to do
more stuff with me I'd like to get to
know you better and all that I'm doing
this because I'd love for you there's
plenty of real estate on this planet I
can't buy it all it's impossible
you can go buy your deals he can buy his
deals Robert can buy his deals I can buy
all my deals and there's still lots of
deals
like there's no shortage of deals it's I
also look for people that I could like
hey man how could I do deals together
with people and scale faster
because I'd rather this this much of 80
billion
than that much or 2 billion
I'd rather a little tiny exquisite
you know and that's how all these guys
do it I mean you want to get to the top
of the food chain and make a legacy and
really leave something big you start
thinking big you start thinking 10 times
whatever you're thinking 10 times it's
not about getting the right answer it's
about being able to use the information
in the right situation
and so you have to go into a situation
knowing something's going to be stable
particularly in an environment where
there's a lot of variables and we live
in an environment right now with a lot
of variables with covid the mass the
election coming who knows there's a
million different things going on out
there you cannot you cannot add
another variable to that many variables
so the thing that you need to do is you
have to be the stable
person in an environment where there's a
lot of craziness going on I had so many
people tell me well it depends it
depends on the situation no dude you you
need to be the same person every time
regardless of the situation
because if you try to change to every if
you try that's the problem with this
whole adapting thing
if you're going to adapt to every
situation that happens in life you'll
never become anything
because you'll just be a chameleon one
second then a tiger the next Second and
then a kitty cat the next Second and
then he roadkill the next
you'll just become whatever is going on
in the environment and you'll never
become strong the strong you you should
be and and
this disparity in America particularly
in America and around the world the
disparity between the the people that
have something and everybody else is
getting bigger and bigger if you don't
like the way that is
if you don't like the way that game's
working out you need to improve your
skill set so that you can go get yours
for you and your family because it's out
there I'm just telling you the the
opportunities out there is whether you
want to open your eyes be conscious the
whole time go look at it and figure out
how do you get your share of the of the
American dream you're gonna get what you
go look for
if you're looking for a purple elephant
you'll find one this weekend even though
there's not one on this planet how many
of you can look for a purple elephant
look for one I'll bet you find one if
you look for a 32 unit deal you'll find
a 32 unit deal if you look for the
credit you find the credit you'll find
the debt you'll find the cash you'll
find the deals you'll if you're looking
for a partner you can find a partner if
all you do is keep looking for excuses I
don't have time I don't have money I
can't do it I'm black I'm Brown I'm too
young I'm too old I'm a girl I'm this I
got a job I'm too young how old are you
man
[Music]
you can
literally what's it called the attorney
with me yeah
foreign
[Music]
the better the mom you are the worse the
dad
so I'm a good father I am a terrible
mother
I'm like jump
that my wife is like we're on the 30th
floor
yeah I'm a father I'm a guy right so I
just it's a different vibe and my mom
tried to be a mom and a dad and she
couldn't
and so you be the mom you know I don't
know where your dad is but if I could
anyway and by the way the mom and the
dad can only do so much and then an
uncle needs to step
okay all right guys let's get back in
here appreciate you being here I hope
your pretend you to do more stuff
I used to listen to guys that were
Millionaires and they were like when I
look back now I'm like oh they were all
like don't get bigger bigger's not
better flying to the radar uh you know
it it what matters is how much you make
how much you net how much you keep save
your money everything all those guys
that are worth two and three and four
million even some guys are worth five
and ten they're all about contractions
that's right they're trying to save
conservative because when you start
talking to these other dudes I'm not
talking about myself now when I get
around guys that are worth 600 million
4 billion they never talk about that did
they think my money's chump money
they're like that that's not money right
there dude look quit looking at your
notes okay what do you want to do here
someone else
nobody said yeah okay what do you want
what does Tommy need to do Tommy's
making 400 Grand worried about somebody
that's no good
okay where does Tommy need to go
screw the mechanics okay where you've
been screw where you've been
dude where where are you in the right
vehicle you have to change
okay where you been means nothing
none of this the the chick that you
hired in New Orleans what you did last
year did none of it
no no you just want to skip now dude you
just want to drop the past
it doesn't matter okay so my goal for
you I don't know if it's your goal but
I'm hearing you say some of this let's
just go to number one in your Market
it's easy to do your mom and dad said
you know tone it down tone it down you
know have some reasonable how many of
you heard that reasonable goals
something attainable and that what
happens is when the goal is attainable
it's no longer exciting because if you
can go get it easily you're going to
take it for granted
if you can go get it easily you're going
to take it for granted yeah so I wake up
this morning there's no milk in my
refrigerator
I don't drink milk but I like milk to
make froth for my cappuccino
and I like the froth really thick so it
takes a lot of milk right and I'm now
pissed off man there's no freaking milk
it's not that there's no milk dude I
want the milk now and I want it now more
than ever because it's not in there so
if it's attainable if a million dollars
was attainable to everybody wouldn't be
worth anything
and by the way it is attainable to
everybody
so
I believe that the bigger the giant the
more unattainable the goal is okay uh
the the least likely if it's real for
you the least likely you are to give up
on that goal I think a lot of the
reasons why you see people going down
is because the goals are so low why
would I be excited who could possibly be
excited about making enough money to pay
their bills just because you're great
doesn't mean you don't want money in
fact the greater you are the more money
you're going to want so if you want
great people
I hear companies always talk about I
can't find great people because you
don't pay them anything man right so
like if I if I give you if I offer you
700 Grand right now can you swim
yeah you any good I'm okay yeah so if I
offer you 700 Grand right now and say
hey dude you got to go swim after that
boat you got to catch it look you're not
going to worry about how cold the water
is your water's probably freezing ass
cold right you're gonna you're gonna if
you're Money Motivated
okay you're gonna fly in there but but
let's say I put 700 grand out there and
say whoever gets to the boat first
exactly well what Trace exactly what
would you do it would you do it probably
I think anyone in the anyone in the
world would do it I don't know unless
you're a billionaire and you're like
yeah then 700 you're not motivated by
seven exactly right you'd want more than
700 yeah you'd be like yeah I'll do it
but you know what I know billionaires
would actually be the first people to
hit the water exactly because they
understand money they understand man
it's worth me paying that price to get
the 700 because they know what to do
with 700 a lot of people are not Money
Motivated because they simply don't know
what to do with money every time they
get it they actually lose it one people
should be invested in the beginning and
just in themselves every chance you get
to to go to something that could
possibly help you has a if it has a one
percent chance of even adding to the
value you have in your spend the money
don't sit on money money's useless
so
if you have five thousand dollars left
in your account I would spend the whole
5 000 on yourself
when you spend money on yourself you're
going to start getting better at
whatever you're doing
if you just keep doing it if you keep
spinning it just because you spent it
once and it didn't work go do it again
and then again and then again that that
has been one thing in my life like if
you ask me hey what's one thing I always
invest in me first
not the business not the business not
the real estate me my condition how am I
doing am I around the right people am I
listening like I don't care what it is
dinner lunch Charities I just go to
anything anything where I think there's
other people doing well
like I just want to hear somebody say
something it just inspires me as long as
I got money somebody will make sure for
me yeah as long as I have influence
money as long as I have the gold look if
you have the goal you make the rules but
and that is that has existed for
thousands of years it will not be a it
will never be violated that is the rule
and and I know people say that sounds
terrible I I always looked at this game
like I want to have the gold I want to
make the rules I'll find somebody that
gave up on their dreams
billions of people give up on their
dreams every day you're never going to
think you're not going to fix that
shortage overnight I would encourage
everybody to become more like me so that
at least you get on the other side of
this rainbow and say oh I know what it
looks like over here because most people
never even get why
because because people people ask this
question that you just asked
and and that question is based on a give
up it's based on a surrender to the game
okay should everybody play the game yeah
everybody should play the game should
everybody learn backgammon yes because
you should learn backgammon because it's
a cool game to play uh should everybody
learn how to make money uh yeah you
should because if you give up before you
do it
you'll never know you'll never know man
and I'm telling you money
like just this concept money won't make
you happy where did that come from
lies and deception lies and deception
yeah yeah because I'm most people that
say money won't make you happy don't
have any money or they're trying to get
your money yeah and I'm gonna tell you
money has made me happier
as long as you get the right amount of
it nobody ever got rich buying homes
ever in the history of the world number
one number two never in the history of
the world has there there been wealth
created because you saved money okay
people should be invested money first in
themselves to get great at something I
don't care what it is waiting tables
bussing tables like you got to get great
at something first you don't need to
become an investor first accepting
yourself I was 25 years old got out of a
treatment center for drug addiction I
was forty thousand dollars worth of debt
debt
um like nobody trusted me nobody
believed in me I didn't believe in me I
had no self-esteem I was wrecked nobody
to look to and I'm like I got one thing
in front of me my job it was a layup
right and basketball is the easiest shot
I could take I need to get good at this
job and I hated the job I had by the way
it's not like I loved it or had a
passion for it I'm like I need to just
put my head down focus on this one thing
and learn how to increase my income and
get control of that so I invested in me
and I started getting better at my job
that's all I did when I got a little bit
of confidence that that was starting to
move forward and I had a little extra
money three grand four grand I started
figuring out okay what can I do with
this money said this money could start
working
and that has been
I don't code anything I don't know
anything about technology like uh I've
started a bunch of businesses with no
money no debt
um written eight books now because what
I'm sharing with people is what worked
for me and I'm just telling people like
this worked for me this took me from
nothing
to
have an a number of businesses that are
very very successful with no debt we
borrowed no money uh to start the first
companies a lot of hard work and then
when I got any extra dough what I did
was I took it and put it in one place
where I knew I would not lose it and for
me that's not the stock market it's
definitely not the crypto Market it's
not Bonds it's not paper like I don't
want to trade a piece of paper
that everybody knows is garbage I think
everybody knows that you know this piece
of paper is full of lies it's got lies
all over it
you know it's got a guy I don't know I
thought he was a president he's not he's
got the White House in the back it's got
In God We Trust I mean this is
fabricated this is this is worth no more
than this piece of paper right here like
why would I trade one piece of paper for
another piece of garbage paper
that Wall Street certifies just because
they put their little stamp on and call
themselves BlackRock or Blackstone or
gold men you know or JP Morgan these
people are making trillions and
trillions of dollars we need to think
more like those guys than like your
uncle who's saving money in the backyard
you guys that are just getting started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
the first thing I had to do to get my
life moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm going to beat that son up every
morning so that I had the discipline and
the control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I have the same
weekends or for the week
I was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people making poor choices
at 25 years old I cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life that weren't committed to the
same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day kick start your day get going in
your day to give you a sense of respect
for yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that son up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I
started building respect for myself
start believing in myself so that I can
go out into the world and maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when I go into
this meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
you know this morning I got up took my
kids to to school
I took him by myself I didn't want my
wife in the car with me I want I want to
take them I want to spend time with them
uh by the way I'm the one that put him
to sleep last night I put him to bed
tell them a story I do a little dance
for him boom I put him down
you know so so I'm looking for moments
to be that guy right so look like that's
the whole 10x thing the 10x thing has
nothing to do with balance
if you look for balance you're gonna
miss this whole deal like
like I'm not playing the balance game
I'm playing the 10x game the 10x game is
look I'm going to be a superhero
to myself though
I'm trying to be my hero
so so
um you you got to make time man like
most of my career I didn't have kids
they just came on eight years ago
and uh so I had to change my schedule a
little bit but all you really have to do
is just make it a priority say okay I'm
a fine time farm and the second part is
you also need to get some help around
you need to get some help so that you
can do the other things you need to do
so that you don't turn into an
eight-year-old
you know see it's fun for me to dip in
and out but I have help around to
support me with the rest of time because
the reality is
it's not my purpose to be
with Sabrina
eight hours a day
you know my job's to be with my job's to
my my goal and my dream is to run my
business Influence People Help people
you know learn my own stuff to eight
hours a day I got my own school I'm
going to
so you know also on the weekends like my
job's not to spend what what's two days
Saturday and Sunday that's 48 Hours my
job my job as a father is not to spend
48 hours with my kids Non-Stop
my job's just been some good quality
time with my kids
make sure I influence him as a father
and then uh
let them go crazy with somebody else
sketchy people sketchy people can't see
everything you know I've I've learned
this in my own life and with other
people like people that take shortcuts
can't see very well
and and and like you you already you can
see everything I'm doing you see the
e-commerce you see the traditional you
see the the sales calls that we make you
see what I'm doing on social you see the
real estate place you see everything I'm
doing
so another person could study everything
that I'm doing and not see everything
I'm doing because
they're sketchy and they're like stuck
right here they're criminals
they're they're they're they're they're
they're they're taking shortcuts and
they're they're looking for shortcuts
and all they see is shortcuts they don't
they can't see everything so the more
honest the person is the more they can
see and the less honest a person is the
less they can see it's it's why a thief
a thief you know Robs a house and steals
less than he could have made just
servicing the same exact house
right the guy would have given more
money to like take care of him if he
could see instead he saw a watch and
took the watch you can change my life
your money cannot change my life you can
give me a stack of money as big as you
want you ain't got enough there's nobody
on this stream not one person on this
stream a combined 50 of you cannot
change my financial life it's impossible
but you could change my life your
charity could change my life it could
give us more purpose you could help me
with my Foundation
in your part of the world you could help
me with my legacy you could help my
children when I'm not here she's 30
years old maybe I'm not here and you're
in Singapore you're in Dubai or you're
in Lafayette Louisiana or you're in
Indianapolis and you see her and she
needs some help you can help me
you can help her but you can't help her
if you ain't got anything if you don't
have a job an opportunity you don't have
money you're worried about your own
stuff you can't even keep your own
refrigerator full how can you help
Sabrina it's impossible for those of you
who feel like he's preaching at you it's
cause you're resisting
the lecture
you're resisting the answers those of
you who are like give me more bro give
me more I need the six pieces it's not
about having the six pieces of data it's
about executing the six pieces of data
so if I didn't care about you guys I
just go on my life and go buy another
piece of real estate tomorrow and then I
do a second deal and a third deal and a
fourth deal and a fifth deal if it was
just about the money okay so we're here
to help you stay here right now stay
here stay present you got to keep making
a decision
okay let me add a piece see Elena's
getting it right now Joe Joe mascali is
getting it Joe nice beard bro damn
incredible where are you where in the UK
are you in Essex just outside of London
I know where Essex is okay uh you're
close you're close to Saint Hill aren't
you what saying he don't know
Oh I thought you said Sussex okay hey
let me ask you something how often do
you have to take care of that beard
I'm pretty much stroke it a lot yeah you
stroked yourself a lot huh yeah I go I
go to The Barbers you know get it lined
up but that's pretty much it yeah but
every morning every morning you you
working it out don't you 100 brush it
out in the morning yeah definitely there
you go thank you mate thank you for
being here okay now folks what is your
beard that you take care of every day
because I know a lot of you think man I
just can't stay with it promise you
I'm gonna give you a list of things that
you can stay with in fact I want you to
write these things down I want you to
write down the things that you do every
day because a lot of you think you can't
stay with it and it's a lie
write down some things that you do every
day that take zero energy and you do it
every day Joe takes care of his bit
beard he calls it stroking
he doesn't even call it taking care of
the beard okay how many of you put
makeup on every day all you ladies out
there every day you do it okay you do
these things naturally I just want to
recover for you I want to recover for
you your belief in yourself
it is not true that if you that you have
failed you you are taking care of you
Stuart every day you're taking care of
your eyeballs right now
you're taking care of yourself every day
the problem is and this is what this is
what Brandon is talking about
the problem is you're not taking care of
the things that can get you up to the
top of the mountain
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Alex hermosi
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there hard work will
not make you rich I get driven nuts by
the amount of gurus and influencers and
whatever who want to brag and say no one
cannot work me I'm the best in the world
so many people outwork me I still make
more money than them there has to be
something else one of the things that
Grimes